[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well
I wanted to leave a little extra time
for this today
um important issue slightly more
important than the The Walrus if
anything could be
back in May a trans activist an
influencer by the name of Eli Ehrlich
announced a felony conspiracy on
Instagram
Ehrlich excitedly told 40 000 plus
followers about a brilliant plan to
circumvent state laws Banning doctors
for prescribing hormones to gender
confused minors ehrlich's genius scheme
which was laid out in strenuous detail
and remained published on Instagram for
nearly three months before lives of tick
tock finally noticed it and reposted it
to Twitter the scheme was to gather
leftover prescription hormone pills and
mail them
to anyone who wants them
no questions asked we're told here was
the actual uh post it said there are
over 20 states trying to criminalize
hormone therapy particularly for Trans
youth so my friends and I had an idea
sending out our extra prescriptions
around the country if you need hormones
I'm working with a distribution Network
to get you access everything is free no
questions asked we have hundreds of
doses of testosterone
estradiol and uh
spironolactone I think is whatever it is
all that is available right now all are
prescribed by doctors and unused each
package comes with information on dosage
obtaining blood work etc I realize this
is a Band-Aid solution we need full
access to affirmative medical care for
professionals immediately
however missing a single dose of
hormones can be devastating especially
for Trans teens and those new to
hormones these laws are outrageous and I
can't wait for them to be overturned in
the meantime DM me if you need HRT or if
you have over over prescribed hormones
that you'd like to send out
now in a response to a question posed by
follower Ehrlich confirmed that this
black market drug Network can
realistically ship to anywhere in North
America
which means that the drug smuggling
operation is international
this is not a new thing either in
September Ehrlich made something of an
anniversary post on Instagram
celebrating 11 years on hormones in
commemoration of the big event and as a
wise old trans Sage dispensing morsels
of wisdom Ehrlich shared 11 mantras for
hormone use and Mantra 6 was
redistribute your extra hormones to
people who can't access slash afford
them
this Mantra by the way was explained in
a YouTube video posted a few months
earlier where Ehrlich offers what looks
and sounds like a confession that you
hear during the plea bargain phase at
trial uh let's listen
every month for the past several years
I've ordered a double dose of hormones
and testosterone blockers
I save all the extra pills for my best
friends my closest lovers and my worst
enemies
I just hope these little pills can bring
some joy into their life I have the
opportunity to give life-saving
medication to people who need it and it
basically costs me nothing
a few months ago I posted on Instagram
asking for testosterone for a friend who
actually already had a prescription his
doctor was out of town and he couldn't
get a new one within hours my story was
taken down and I received a warning by
the administrators now of course I know
it's against Instagram rules to share
substances and I wasn't particularly
surprised that it was removed but I was
still upset so yeah I know it's illegal
duh so is changing my Social Security to
female without medical treatment so was
crossing the street outside my apartment
instead of using the crosswalk oh yeah I
mean jaywalking is exactly like
trafficking and prescription pills
illegally right
now in that video having apparently only
just developed this fetish for
announcing federal crimes on the
internet Ehrlich was a little more
cautious there's a disclaimer quote
unquote early on claiming that the whole
thing is merely hypothetical
but after getting a little taste of
self-incrimination and having apparently
enjoyed it so much early became far more
Brash and bold in subsequent
pronouncements leading up finally to the
Instagram announcement in which the
whole drug distribution Enterprise is
laid out in detail yet
as acknowledged in the clip that we just
played
all of this is illegal it is in fact so
illegal that it would be impossible for
me to count all the laws that it breaks
it is illegal to share your prescription
medication with anyone who was not
prescribed for it is illegal to
facilitate the exchange of other
people's prescription drugs it is
illegal to ship Controlled Substances
through the mail it is illegal to
distribute drugs across state lines it
is illegal to send them to other
countries
all of these drugs are illegal for
anyone who is not a doctor or pharmacist
to distribute period
and for good reason
the substance is being shipped across
the country by erlich's ragtat group of
drug Peddlers are dangerous potent Laden
with potentially severe side effects and
they make irreversible changes to your
body
in participating in this scheme not just
participating but organizing it Ehrlich
has violated dozens of state laws
federal laws and international laws
making the perpir uh eligible for
decades in federal prison
this has been done and talked about
openly on every available platform yet
up to this moment there has been not so
much as an Instagram suspension in
response
much less a raid by the DEA
why
well because Eli Ehrlich is in a
privileged class the most privileged
class that has ever existed in the West
that's why the confessed drug trafficker
responded so brazenly when I first
started tweeting about this issue on
Friday after Libs of tick tock reported
on it
um
and I started tweeting about it and
talking about it and and uh from Ehrlich
there was never any denial
still to this point no denial none
instead Ehrlich defended the criminal
activity telling me that these drugs are
life-saving medications
which is just more confirmation that
you're doing what it appears that you're
doing which is illegally uh Distributing
the drugs when I remarked that this
response may be the first time in my
life that someone has tried to dunk on
me by publicly confessing to a federal
crime Ehrlich replied it's an honor Matt
Ehrlich also thanked us for advertising
quote unquote the trafficking operation
and fully embrace the label drug
Smuggler
said it might go in the in the bio
now it should be noted for what it's
worth that Ehrlich was slightly less
excited to embrace the label accused
sexual abuser threatening to sue me for
libel when I repost when I reposted
reports from other outlets noting that
Ehrlich has along with being a confessed
drug Smuggler uh has indeed been accused
of sexual assault by multiple alleged
victims
and you know that's that's a fact that's
that's the news there that's the
accusation has been made
I don't know if it's true or not but
that was the accusations
so I suppose we can add the law to the
list of things this person does not
begin to understand
thinking that I could be sued for libel
for reposting a news report
but no surprise coming from someone who
casually captions their selfies with
criminal conspiracy confessions
but go ahead and file your lawsuit Eli I
I have I could please do I have a
feeling that Discovery might be a very
interesting process
now
Eli I admit that um you have some
justification for being so brazen After
all you've never been held accountable
for anything in your entire life
you are privileged and spoiled and
literally never in your life have you
been held accountable for anything
so why should that change now I mean why
should Justice catch up with you now you
ask
well part of the reason why people like
you skate by enjoying your own set of
rules is that so often
people like the rest of us have grown to
Simply accept this absurd State of
Affairs there's no reason why the system
would punish someone like you if if
nobody even bothers to demand it because
we assume it's not going to happen
and maybe that assumption will be
correct but maybe nothing much will
happen even if we do demand it or maybe
you would actually be made to face some
sort of consequence for the first time
in your life either way
we're gonna find out
because I am not going to Simply accept
that being trans makes you Above the Law
even less am I going to accept the
illegal distribution of dangerous drugs
to minors
I'm not going to let this go or shrug my
shoulder and say well nothing we can do
and move on
uh no no more of that
I'm going to use the resources at my
disposal which are considerably greater
than the resources at your disposal to
make sure that Justice is done here
why
well because you're Distributing
dangerous drugs to minors across the
country and this is only the tip of the
iceberg thanks to Predators like
yourself kids have many avenues for
obtaining these substances without any
doctor's approval much less parental
consent
this is what parents have to worry about
now that their children will in secret
begin to medically transition with the
help of drugs they obtain through
Instagram
now I doubt that you're the country's
most prolific illegal distributor of
prescription drugs but you are the one
that we're going to make an example of
because we have to start somewhere
also Eli I should note that I just don't
like your attitude I think you need some
humility in your life
and I I am generous enough to help you
develop that virtue
so
here's what's going to happen
I want anyone concerned about this
criminal activity to do the responsible
thing
and reported to the relevant authorities
if you see something say something how
many times have we been told that
and let's start with the DEA
you can easily find the link on Google
but here is the URL we'll put it up on
the screen for you
dea.gov submit Dash tip from there you
can submit a tip either anonymously or
not it's up to you
and you can note that there is someone
by the name of Eli Ehrlich who has
announced an intention
um to participate in the illegal
distribution of prescription drugs
across the country
we're not finished Ehrlich despite not
understanding math statistics the law or
for that matter human biology is a PhD
candidate at the University of
California Santa Cruz
the university ought to know and ought
to act upon the fact that one of their
phds is an admitted drug trafficker so
yesterday I reached out personally to
the chancellor of the University Cynthia
K larive to ask her about this matter
and I haven't heard back yet now I'm
going to give her the rest of today to
respond and to explain what steps are
being taken to address this very
troubling situation but if I still could
not get a hold of her after today then
it will be my duty and responsibility as
a citizen to share the publicly
available contact information for the
University Administration and encourage
all of my thousands of listeners and
viewers and the millions who follow me
on social media to call and email
demanding that the university take
action
I hope it doesn't come to that and but
but I have a feeling that it will after
all the university said nothing earlier
in the summer when Ehrlich posted a
tweet calling for the assassination of
Supreme Court Justices
they remind they remain silent then too
but silence will not be an option
anymore
what is it that they say again oh a
silence is violence
we're not done yet Ehrlich having used
social media and Instagram in particular
to coordinate this criminal activity
should be indefinitely suspended there
has rarely been a more deserving
candidate for de-platforming as this
account is an actual danger to children
reason enough for a permanent ban
so I'll walk you through the steps to
file your report with Instagram uh you
go to Instagram first go to Eli
ehrlich's page then hit the three little
dots at the top right of the screen and
select report and from there select
report account and then select it's
posting content that shouldn't be on
Instagram and then select sale of
illegal or regulated goods and finally
drugs
everyone listening to me right now
should do that
what should happen from here is that
Eli is kicked out of school D platformed
arrested and put under criminal
investigation by both federal and state
authorities that's what should happen
that would be the just and right result
here
will any event happen
well there's only one way to find out
and even if every institution decides to
accept ehrlich's trans your way out of
jail free card a very distinct
possibility after all these institutions
are ideologically ideologically captured
as previously established but even still
at least by using all of our platforms
to amplify this story we could ensure
that whenever anyone Googles this person
in the future potential employers or
anybody else they will immediately see
that Eli Ehrlich is a confessed drug
Peddler
this is already working we've already
prompted several news outlets including
Fox to cover the Scandal and um we're
going to continue because we can make
sure that this creep is branded by these
admitted crimes
for eternity
and that's something at least
but most of all
we can send a message that we do not
accept the hierarchy that our society
has put in place we are not going to Bow
our heads submissively as the privileged
classes break the law and harm our
children at will
we're just not
we're gonna fight back
and that's what this is and that is also
why Eli Ehrlich who again has confessed
to Distributing drugs illegally across
the country to minors is
canceled
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the Subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast